This story takes place so long ago here in America that the stuff that we normally think of as long ago is in the far, far distant future. It's 100 years before Thomas Jefferson and George Washington are even born-- the year 1635. That year, this guy named Roger Williams, who was this charismatic young preacher, gets banished by the brand new state of Massachusetts, because he goes around questioning a lot of things, including the central premise of what the settlers were trying to do.
这个故事发生在美国很久以前，久到我们通常认为的“很久以前”在当时看来都是极其遥远的未来。那是托马斯·杰斐逊和乔治·华盛顿出生前100年的1635年。那一年，一个叫罗杰·威廉姆斯的男人，一位极具魅力的年轻传教士，被崭新的马萨诸塞州放逐了，因为他四处质疑许多事情，包括定居者们所做之事的中心前提。
In particular, he was questioning the teachings of a guy named John Winthrop. Winthrop was the elected leader of the colonists, and he was very clear about what they were doing there in the new world. They were creating God's kingdom on earth. It was going to be a religious community. They would obey God's laws. That was the point of it.
特别是，他在质疑一个叫约翰·温思罗普的人的教导。温思罗普是殖民者的民选领袖，他非常清楚他们在那个新世界是在做什么。他们正在地球上建立上帝的王国。那将是一个宗教社区。他们要服从上帝的法律。这就是建立它的意义所在。
This young guy, Roger Williams, had the radical idea that maybe there should be a separation of church and state on this new continent. So the powers that be, including John Winthrop, who, at this point, was the governor of Massachusetts, got together and agreed that this could not stand. This radical, anti-Christian agenda had no place on this new continent. And they voted to expel Roger Williams, send him back to England.
这个年轻人罗杰·威廉姆斯有一个激进的想法，也许在这个新大陆上应该实行政教分离。于是，当权者，包括此时已是马萨诸塞州州长的约翰·温思罗普，聚在一起，一致认为这种情况绝不能容忍。这个激进的、反基督教的议程在这个新大陆上没有立足之地。他们投票决定驱逐罗杰·威廉姆斯，将他送回英国。
In this dark hour, one person steps in, secretly, to help Williams. That person was the governor of Massachusetts, William's main adversary, John Winthrop.
在这黑暗时刻，有一个人偷偷介入，帮助了威廉姆斯。那个人就是马萨诸塞州州长，也是威廉姆斯的主要对手，约翰·温思罗普。
There are all these fascinating hints that Winthrop really liked Roger Williams.
有各种令人着迷的暗示表明，温思罗普真的很喜欢罗杰·威廉姆斯。
This is Ted Widmer, historian, director of the Kluge Center for Research at the Library of Congress and, by the way, a former speechwriter for President Clinton.
这是泰德·威德默，历史学家，国会图书馆克鲁格研究中心主任，顺便提一下，他还是克林顿总统的前讲稿撰写人。
In fact, at the crucial moment when Roger Williams is about to be arrested and put on a ship and sent back to England, Winthrop sends word privately-- we don't quite know how-- that Williams really ought to go down to Narragansett Bay. And Winthrop helps him to escape, even as he's publicly voting for his banishment.
事实上，在罗杰·威廉姆斯即将被捕、被送上船遣返回英国的关键时刻，温思罗普私下传话——我们不太清楚他是怎么做到的——说威廉姆斯确实应该去纳拉甘西特湾。即便在公开投票支持驱逐他的时候，温思罗普还是帮他逃脱了。
Williams does go to Narragansett Bay, where he founds the state of Rhode Island. And then he and the guy whose administration just kicked him out had this kind of amazing correspondence, which lasted for years. The governor, Winthrop, wanted to hear how Williams was surviving, and Williams, all of a sudden, is the leader of his own colony. And among other things, he needs advice.
威廉姆斯确实去了纳拉甘西特湾，并在那里创立了罗德岛州。后来，他和那个刚把他赶走的政府的领导人保持了长达数年的惊人通信。州长温思罗普想知道威廉姆斯是如何生存下来的，而威廉姆斯突然成了自己殖民地的领袖。除其他事项外，他需要建议。
Williams is adjusting from having been this dissenting figure, this person who was very quick to point out what was wrong in the way Massachusetts was governed, to suddenly having to organize a government and get the people even crazier than him to tow the line. And he's complaining to Winthrop about how hard it is to organize a government.
威廉姆斯正在从一个持不同政见者，一个非常迅速地指出马萨诸塞州政府治理方式错误的人，转变为不得不组织政府、并让那些比他更疯狂的人遵守纪律的人。他正向温思罗普抱怨组织政府有多难。
So this is a letter from the person who's been banished to the person who, more or less, banished him, and yet it's very friendly. It says, "Much honored sir, the frequent experience of your loving ear, ready and open toward me, emboldened me to request a word of private advice with the soonest convenience it may be by this messenger."
所以这是一封从被放逐者写给大体上放逐了他的人的信，而且它非常友好。信中写道：“备受尊敬的先生，我经常感受到您乐于倾听、对我敞开胸怀，这使我更有胆量请求通过这位信使，尽早与您私下交流意见。”
It's a little hard to get through the 17th century tone, but there's an enormous affection always underlying what he's saying to him, pouring his heart out to the person who is kind of a surrogate father.
要读懂17世纪的语气有点难，但他对他所说的话背后始终蕴含着巨大的深情，向这位如同代理父亲一般的人倾诉衷肠。
Does he ever actually say, how could you do this to me? You kicked me out?
他有没有真的问过，你当时怎么能那样对我？你把我赶了出来？
The tone comes out, but he never says it explicitly. Actually, in the next line after that, he says, "The condition of myself and those few families here planting with me you know full well," which is a pretty interesting sentence. It's sort of like, you know why I'm here, and you know how I got here. But they don't. No, they don't really dwell on it.
那种语气流露了出来，但他从未明确说出口。事实上，在那之后的一行，他说：“我和这里与我一同耕作的几个家庭的情况，您非常清楚，”这是一句相当有趣的句子。就好像在说，你知道我为什么会在这，也知道我是怎么到这的。但他们并不（提及）。不，他们确实没有深究这件事。
If you think about it, the only place their relationship could exist at all was through these letters. The letters were this paper-thin space where these people, who could not have had any other way to be friends, had this exchange that seemed very important to both of them.
如果你仔细想想，他们唯一能建立关系的地方就是通过这些信件。这些信件是一个薄如蝉翼的空间，这些人本没有其他方式成为朋友，却进行了这对他们双方似乎都非常重要的交流。
And it's funny, you know, how letters really do not work that way for many of us anymore. If anything, we have so many different ways to stay in touch with each other that we do not even notice that we're staying in touch over long distances.
有趣的是，你知道，对于我们许多人来说，信件真的不再那样运作了。如果说有什么不同的话，我们现在有太多不同的方式保持联系，以至于我们甚至没注意到我们正在跨越长距离保持联系。
I think it's so easy to communicate that there's almost no reason to communicate anything of interest, you know? It's become like breathing. And if you listen to cell phone conversations on the train, it's always just monosyllables like, "hi, I'm here," or, "I'll be there at 5:19 instead of 5:18." And it's the most boring verbiage you'll ever hear, listening to someone else talking into their cell phone. And back then, it was extremely difficult to write a letter. You weren't sure if it was going to be delivered.
我认为沟通变得太容易了，以至于几乎没有理由沟通任何有趣的事情，你知道吗？它已经变得像呼吸一样。如果你在火车上听手机对话，那总是单音节词，比如“嗨，我到了”，或者“我会5点19分到，而不是5点18分”。当你听到别人对着手机说话时，那是你能听到的最无聊的词藻。而在那个年代，写一封信极其困难。你甚至不确定它是否会被送达。
And because letters took more work, people made sure they said something.
而且因为写信更费工夫，人们会确保写点什么。
And there were real things to say. I mean, every week brought a new challenge.
而且确实有实实在在的事情要说。我的意思是，每一周都带来新的挑战。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Every now and then, you still do get this kind of correspondence, where people write letters because that is the only way they could have any interaction.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目。偶尔，你仍然会收到这种信件，人们写信是因为那是他们进行互动的唯一方式。
And today on our radio program, we are devoting most of the hour to a story like that-- of an unusual relationship that mostly happened in letters, this one between a 10-year-old girl and an enemy of the United States of America, a man accused of being a dictator, a drug runner, a murderer, a man accused of double-crossing the United States.
今天我们的广播节目，我们将用大部分时间讲述这样一个故事——一段主要发生在信件中的非同寻常的关系，这段关系发生在一个10岁女孩和美利坚合众国的敌人之间，一个被指控为独裁者、毒贩、杀人犯、被指控背叛美国的人。
And we have a little story at the end of the hour about what it is like to get a letter every single day for eight years from your own husband. Stay with us.
在本节目最后，我们还有一个关于从你自己的丈夫那里连续八年每天收到一封信是什么感觉的小故事。请继续收听。
Act One, Who Put the Pistol in Epistolary?
第一幕，谁把手枪放进了书信里？
Andrea Morningstar has the story of two pen pals. One of them a young girl in the Midwest. The other, somebody who was considered, at the time, an international, or at least hemispheric, menace. We first aired this story back in 2003.
安德烈娅·莫宁斯塔带来了关于两个笔友的故事。其中一个是中西部的年轻女孩，另一个是当时被认为具有国际性，或者至少是半球性威胁的人。我们曾在2003年首次播出这个故事。
When you're driving to Palmer from the west, the first thing you'll notice are these strange orange cliffs up ahead of you, rising above the pine-covered hills. They would make sense in Utah or the Mojave Desert, but here in the lush green hills of Michigan's Upper Peninsula, they stick out and look almost scary. This is the site of the Palmer Mines. The air in Palmer is sooty and metallic, and a black dust settles down on the homes of the miners.
当你从西边开车前往帕尔默时，你首先会注意到前方那些奇怪的橙色悬崖，耸立在长满松树的山丘之上。它们出现在犹他州或莫哈韦沙漠或许说得通，但在这里，在密歇根州上半岛郁郁葱葱的绿色山丘中，它们显得格外突兀，甚至有些吓人。这里是帕尔默矿区的所在地。帕尔默的空气中弥漫着煤灰和金属味，黑色的灰尘落在矿工的房子上。
A few miles down the road from here, Sarah York grew up in a house that her parents built. Her dad, Mitchell, worked for the mine for years until he got a job as a corrections officer at the nearby prison. Pauline, Sarah's mom, worked as a dental hygienist.
离这儿几英里远的地方，莎拉·约克在她父母建造的房子里长大。她的爸爸米切尔在矿场工作多年，直到他在附近的监狱找到了一份惩教官的工作。莎拉的妈妈波琳是一名牙科保健员。
One night in February in 1988, they were all at home watching 60 Minutes. That night, Mike Wallace was interviewing General Manuel Noriega. He was the big news at the time. Here's Sarah.
1988年2月的一天晚上，他们全家在家看《60分钟》。那天晚上，迈克·华莱士正在采访曼努埃尔·诺列加将军。他是当时的大新闻人物。这是莎拉的讲述。
I'm pretty sure that the 60 Minutes program was about charges that were being brought up against him, or just accusations that he was a drug trafficker and a bunch of other stuff.
我敢肯定那期《60分钟》节目是关于对他提起的诉讼，或者仅仅是关于他是毒贩以及其他一堆事情的指控。
I asked my husband. I said, well, what do you think about this?
我问我丈夫。我说，好吧，你对此有什么看法？
This is Sarah's mom, Pauline.
这是莎拉的妈妈，波琳。
Then he says, oh, I don't-- he was kind of giving his opinion about it. And I said, well, I don't really know what to think. But the discussion ended with, he had a pretty nice hat on, though. And Sarah's dad has always had some kind of interesting hat from somewhere or another.
然后他说，哦，我不——他当时在发表意见。我说，好吧，我真的不知道该怎么想。但讨论以“不过他戴的帽子倒挺好看的”而告终。莎拉的爸爸一直都有从某处弄来的各式各样的有趣帽子。
Oh, yeah, I had a Mao hat--
哦，是的，我有一顶毛帽——
Sarah's dad, Mitchell.
莎拉的爸爸，米切尔。
--from China, oh, and different cowboy hats.
——从中国弄来的，哦，还有各种牛仔帽。
And I made the comment that, well, I suppose that you could write to him and ask for a hat.
我说，嗯，我想你可以写信给他，问他要一顶帽子。
Everyone has one down there, or several.
那里每个人都有一顶，或者好几顶。
But I said, I don't think you're going to have much luck. Maybe if a kid did it, then it would happen. And there's Sarah, saying, well, I'll write to him.
但我说，我觉得你不会有什么好运气的。也许如果是个孩子来做，那就有可能了。然后莎拉说，好吧，我写信给他。
You know, maybe he'll send us a hat. We made sure to put in the letter that we I really liked his hat. We had this stationery that I wrote it on that had a partridge on it. We thought it would be a nice touch.
你知道，也许他会送我们一顶帽子。我们特意在信中写道，我真的很喜欢他的帽子。我们用了那种上面有鹧鸪图案的信纸。我们觉得这会是个不错的点缀。
I should mention that Sarah had her 18-month-old baby on her lap when we talked.
我应该提到，当我们交谈时，莎拉怀里正抱着她18个月大的宝宝。
[BABY COOING]
[婴儿咿呀学语声]
And I think I drafted out something on notebook paper, and we worked on it a little bit.
我想我在笔记本纸上起草了一些东西，我们一起修改了一下。
I guess I can say I coached her a little bit. I said, you don't want to just come out right and ask him for a hat, you know? You gotta say something nice. So she did, and just mentioned about how she had been seeing him on TV, and hoped that our countries could still remain friends.
我想我可以说是稍微辅导了她一下。我说，你不能直接开口问他要帽子，你知道吗？你得说点好听的。所以她照做了，只是提到了她在电视上看到他，并希望我们的国家还能保持友好。
It was clear and direct, and she complimented him on the hat. [CHUCKLES] It was simple.
信件清晰直接，她还称赞了他的帽子。[轻笑]这很简单。
Well, I read the first letter and I don't remember writing that. And it's kind of like, I feel like it's a joke coming back to haunt me that my dad played on me in a way. Like, I don't know. He probably was like, oh wouldn't it be cute if she said this?
嗯，我读了第一封信，我不记得写过那个。这就像是我爸开的一个玩笑反过来困扰着我一样。就像，我不知道。他当时可能觉得，哦，如果她这么说不是挺可爱的吗？
"Dear General Noriega, congratulations on the patriotic support of your people. I hope this letter finds you and your countrymen well. I am a 10-year-old American schoolgirl. I study Central America. It is a special interest to me. I have seen you on television often here in the United States. Your hat was greatly admired here. Sadly, we can get nothing like it. I hope friendship will remain--
“亲爱的诺列加将军，祝贺您获得人民的爱国支持。希望这封信送达时，您和您的同胞一切安好。我是一名10岁的美国小学生。我研究中美洲。这对我有特殊的吸引力。我经常在美国的电视上看到您。您的帽子在这里备受赞赏。遗憾的是，我们买不到类似的。希望友谊长存——”
Yeah, I said that, you know, I really liked your hat, and "sadly, we can get nothing like it here." Come on. Jeez, he's got to send me a hat.
是的，我那么说了，你知道，我真的很喜欢你的帽子，“遗憾的是，我们这里买不到类似的。”得了吧。天哪，他肯定得送我一顶帽子。
Well, we just put, "General Manuel Noriega, Panama City, Panama." I mean, there's probably only one General Manuel Noriega there. And it got there. And it was totally amazing, because it was probably about a month later that I went out to get the mail and there was this letter addressed to Sarah, and it had this Panamanian-- some type of a military flag type thing on it. And it was like, whoa.
嗯，我们只写了“曼努埃尔·诺列加将军，巴拿马城，巴拿马”。我的意思是，那里大概只有一位曼努埃尔·诺列加。信送到了。而且这太令人震惊了，因为大约一个月后，我去取信，看到了一封寄给莎拉的信，上面有一个巴拿马的——某种军旗之类的东西。那感觉就像，哇。
I knew she'd get a return. I had a feeling. She was so cute at the time. She was in braces and just got her glasses. I thought she would get an answer. And she did, pretty quickly.
我知道她会收到回信的。我有预感。她当时太可爱了。她戴着牙套，刚戴上眼镜。我觉得她会得到回复的。她确实得到了，而且很快。
She was in fifth grade. And I couldn't stand it. I had to go to the school right away and show her this, because it was pretty amazing.
她当时上五年级。我简直不敢相信。我必须立刻去学校把这个给她看，因为这太不可思议了。
Yeah, it was probably one of the most exciting things that ever happened to me. I get this letter. Everyone loves getting mail, anyway, but from a foreign leader? Wow.
是的，这可能是我经历过的最激动人心的事情之一。我收到了这封信。无论如何，每个人都喜欢收到邮件，但还是来自一位外国领导人？哇。
"Dear Sarah, I feel honored by your letter. I appreciate your message of faith and friendship. I hope you continue sending your message and tell me about yourself and your city. With friendship and appreciation, General Manuel Antonio Noriega."
“亲爱的莎拉，我对你的来信感到荣幸。我很欣赏你传递的信念和友谊。我希望你继续发送你的信息，并告诉我关于你自己和你所在城市的情况。带着友谊和感激，曼努埃尔·安东尼奥·诺列加将军。”
It was just like two sentences. That was all it was. But he did ask her to write again, and to tell him about herself and where she lived.
只有两句话。就这么多。但他确实邀请她再次写信，并告诉他关于她自己和她住的地方。
And I told him about where I was from. I'm from Northern Michigan, which I still think is a pretty special place. It's kind of out there, as far as away from cities. And we get a lot of snow, and it gets really cold in the winter.
我告诉了他我来自哪里。我来自密歇根州北部，我依然认为那是个非常特别的地方。它有点偏远，离城市很远。我们那里雪很多，冬天变得非常冷。
They kept on writing back and forth. It was usually about once a month.
他们继续保持着通信。通常是一个月一次。
At the time these letters were being written, Noriega was as notorious as Saddam Hussein is now. He had just been indicted on US racketeering and drug charges, and images of him were all over the news.
在这些信件被写下的当时，诺列加的臭名昭著程度不亚于现在的萨达姆·侯赛因。他刚在美国被控敲诈勒索和贩毒，关于他的报道充斥着新闻。
Ted Koppel said that Noriega belonged to that special fraternity of international villains-- men like Qaddafi, Idi Amin, and the Ayatollah Khomeini, whom Americans just love to hate. Dan Rather placed him, quote, "at the top of the list of the world's drug thieves and scums." Things had gone so far that he even had a nickname that sounded like a cartoon criminal-- Pineapple Face.
泰德·科佩尔说，诺列加属于那个特殊的国际恶棍兄弟会——像卡扎菲、伊迪·阿明和霍梅尼这样的男人，美国人就是喜欢憎恨他们。丹·拉瑟把他放在了“世界毒贩和人渣名单之首”。事情发展到了这种地步，他甚至得到了一个听起来像卡通罪犯的绰号——“菠萝脸”。
Despite the bad press, Noriega and Sarah continued their correspondence, Sarah telling Noriega about herself, and Noriega telling Sarah about his country.
尽管媒体报道恶劣，诺列加和莎拉依然保持着通信，莎拉告诉诺列加关于她自己的事，诺列加告诉莎拉关于他国家的事。
Everything was really formal, and he never gave me personal details, I don't think, about his life. It was almost more like he was this spokesperson for Panama. And I think that's what he wanted to do. It's not so much make me know him but know his country.
一切都非常正式，我不认为他曾透露过他个人生活的细节。他几乎更像是巴拿马的发言人。我认为这就是他想做的。与其说是让我了解他，不如说是让我了解他的国家。
In this next letter, he says, "I'm very honored with the letter you sent about yourself, your family, and your city. In addition, your interest to the problems in Panama and Central America, and so I'm sending you some books about my country. I hope that you read them and tell me your opinion about them."
在下一封信中，他说：“收到你关于你自己、你的家庭和你所在城市的来信，我深感荣幸。此外，你对巴拿马和中美洲问题的关注，所以我寄给你一些关于我国的书籍。希望你阅读后告诉我你的看法。”
He says, "The US and Panama signed a treaty in 1977 about the Panama Canal, in which the US controls it until December 31, 1999. The only thing that we want is that they comply with this agreement and respect the sovereignty of our small country, Panama."
他说：“美国和巴拿马于1977年签署了关于巴拿马运河的条约，其中规定美国控制该运河至1999年12月31日。我们唯一的要求就是他们遵守这一协议，并尊重我们小国巴拿马的主权。”
"And greetings to your parents and brothers, and keep being so studious as you are--" because I told him that I get good grades-- "because it's people like you who are going to make this a different world and a future full of peace."
“祝你的父母和兄弟们好，继续保持像现在这样好学——”因为我告诉过他我成绩很好——“因为正是像你这样的人，才能够创造一个不同的世界和充满和平的未来。”
Noriega, it has to be said, was a very good pen pal. He was prompt, thorough, polite. He used pretty stationery and sent presents. He even sent a hat like the one Sarah and her dad liked so much. She sent back a picture of her wearing the hat.
必须说，诺列加是一个非常好的笔友。他回复及时、内容详尽、彬彬有礼。他使用漂亮的信纸并寄送礼物。他甚至寄来了一顶莎拉和她爸爸都很喜欢的帽子。她回寄了一张她戴着那顶帽子的照片。
But the letter that came next was the biggest surprise. It arrived in the mail while Sarah was at school. A manila envelope with an 8 by 10 glossy photograph of Noriega wearing a Panamanian hat, and an invitation for Sarah and her mom to visit him, all expenses paid, in Panama City.
但接下来的那封信是最大的惊喜。它在莎拉上学的时候寄到了家里。一个马尼拉纸信封，里面有一张诺列加戴着巴拿马帽子的8乘10英寸光面照片，以及一封邀请莎拉和她妈妈访问巴拿马城，费用全包的邀请函。
I called the school and I asked her. I said, Sarah there's this envelope here. I told her, I'm coming up to the school. And we went into the office and we showed it to the principal. And the principal said, oh, this is fantastic! You're going, aren't you?
我给学校打了电话询问她。我说，莎拉，这里有个信封。我告诉她，我正要赶去学校。我们走进办公室，向校长展示了它。校长说，哦，这太棒了！你们要去，对吧？
But I did go home and I called my mother and I told her about it. I said, well, what do you think? And she said, well, let me think about it. And she said, I'll call you back. And she happened to be over at one of my brothers' houses. And my one brother was a little bit upset with us for carrying on this correspondence with Noriega, because he was reading Time and Newsweek and those kind of things, and he was going with whatever they had to say. And he said, he's a bad guy, and you should have nothing to do with him. Anyway, I was a little bit worried that he was going to try to influence my mother by what he had to say.
但我确实回家给我母亲打了电话，告诉了她这件事。我说，好吧，你觉得怎么样？她说，嗯，让我考虑一下。她说，我会再给你回电话。她当时正好在我其中一个兄弟家。我那个兄弟对我们继续与诺列加通信感到有点不安，因为他一直在读《时代》和《新闻周刊》之类的东西，他全盘接受了他们所说的一切。他说，他是个坏人，你们不应该跟他有任何瓜葛。总之，我有点担心他会试图用他所说的话来影响我母亲。
But nevertheless, she did go home and she called me back and she said, you know, I really don't think that there should be any kind of problem with Sarah going. I think it will be a great experience for her. And I mean, I have my mother's blessing, [CHUCKLES] and I just thought, that's all I need.
但尽管如此，她确实回了家，给我打了电话，她说，你知道，我真的觉得莎拉去应该不会有什么问题。我认为这对她来说会是一次很棒的经历。我是说，我得到了我母亲的祝福，[轻笑]我觉得这就是我所需要的一切。
It seemed important. It seemed very important that we got invited and that we're going to do this. How something happens in your life is always different after that. It had that kind of feeling to it.
这似乎很重要。得到邀请并准备这样做似乎非常重要。生活中发生的某件事之后，一切都会变得不同。它就是那种感觉。
At the time, Noriega wasn't just arguing with the US. He faced dissent at home from Panamanians who didn't want the United States to pull out of Panama, which was scheduled to happen by January of 2000 under the Panama Canal Treaty signed by Jimmy Carter and Omar Torrijos.
当时，诺列加不仅与美国发生争执，他还面临国内巴拿马人的不满，他们不希望美国撤出巴拿马，这原定于2000年1月根据吉米·卡特和奥马尔·托里霍斯签署的巴拿马运河条约实现。
It wasn't clear then if the United States was going to comply with the treaty. The Reagan and Bush administrations both declared that they would not turn the canal over to Panama as long as Noriega was in power.
那时不清楚美国是否会遵守条约。里根政府和布什政府都宣称，只要诺列加还在掌权，他们就不会把运河交给巴拿马。
At a rally where Noriega was addressing the issue, he held up one of Sarah's letters and told the crowd that even American children offer their support. Afterwards, one of his secretaries came up to him and said, why are you showing them the letter? Why not just get the girl?
在一次诺列加就此问题发表讲话的集会上，他举起其中一封莎拉的信，告诉人群即使是美国孩子也支持他。事后，他的一位秘书走上前来问他，你为什么要给他们看那封信？为什么不直接把那个女孩弄来？
And so that's what he did. He invited Sarah and her mother. Sarah's dad stayed at home.
于是他就是这么做的。他邀请了莎拉和她妈妈。莎拉的爸爸留在了家里。
In the years since all this happened, there's no longer much doubt about the way Noriega ran Panama. Human rights groups have documented how the Panamanian defense forces, under his direction, beat, jailed, and deported opposition leaders. An official Panamanian Truth Commission was able to prove that 110 people were killed or disappeared.
自这一切发生以来的这些年里，人们对诺列加统治巴拿马的方式已几乎没有疑问。人权组织记录了巴拿马国防军在他的指挥下如何殴打、监禁和驱逐反对派领导人。官方的巴拿马真相委员会能够证明有110人被杀害或失踪。
Back then, it's not like Sarah's parents thought Noriega was an angel, but they weren't ready to believe the hype in the press, and they encouraged their kids to think for themselves.
那时候，并不是说莎拉的父母认为诺列加是天使，但他们并不准备相信媒体的炒作，他们鼓励孩子们独立思考。
I knew that I was going to get plenty of the bad guy story, so why not get a story from the bad guy? But I don't know that I ever said, I'm going to be the judge of this. I think it was more just, let's see what happens, or, let's see what we can find out.
我知道我会听到很多关于坏人的故事，所以为什么不听听坏人自己的故事呢？但我不知道我是否曾说过，我要来评判这件事。我觉得这更多是，让我们看看会发生什么，或者，让我们看看我们能发现什么。
I remember just getting all our clothes together, because my mom wanted me to look really nice. And I think she might have made me a new dress. And I remember we had to buy me some new socks because my socks were too ratty, and we went to this children's clothing store, which I couldn't believe because, in my mind, I was not a child anymore. And we got the white socks with the turned-down cuff with the ruffle on the bottom, which was pretty borderline too young for me.
我记得整理我们所有的衣服，因为我妈妈想让我看起来真的很得体。我想她可能还给我做了一件新裙子。我记得我们不得不去给我买新袜子，因为我的袜子太破烂了，我们去了这家童装店，我简直不敢相信，因为在我心里，我不再是个孩子了。我们买了那种带褶边翻边的白袜子，那对我来说也太显小了。
I was really into making friendship bracelets at the time out of knotted embroidery floss. You guys probably remember. And I remember making Noriega a bracelet in camouflage colors. [LAUGHS]
我当时非常沉迷于用结实的绣花线制作友谊手环。你们可能还记得。我记得给诺列加做了一个迷彩色的手环。[笑]
The night before we were going to leave, I was busy, busy packing, and we got a phone call from our congressman's office in Washington. And this guy says, well, I know it's a little bit late for this. He says, but I was asked to call you and tell you not to go on this trip. And he says, but I don't suppose I could talk you out of it, could I? And I don't know he didn't really want me to say yeah, I won't go. He didn't really care. I could tell. But, he said, so I just thought I'd give it a try.
出发前一天晚上，我正忙着打包，我们接到了华盛顿国会议员办公室的电话。那个人说，嗯，我知道现在打这个电话有点晚了。他说，但我受托打给你，告诉你们不要参加这次旅行。他说，不过我想我也说不动你们，对吧？我不知道他是不是真的想让我说“好的，我不去了”。他不在乎。我看得出来。但他说，所以我只是想尝试一下。
It was an all-day trip. We left at 6:00 in the morning and we got down there to Miami, and our plane was delayed for three hours. So we got down there at like 9 or 10 o'clock at night.
这是一次全天的旅程。我们早上6点出发，到达迈阿密时，我们的飞机延误了三个小时。所以我们到达时大概是晚上9点或10点。
When we landed, it was dark, and the city looked so enormous. And I don't think, when we were planning the trip, we knew much about what was actually going to take place when we went there.
当我们降落时，天已经黑了，城市看起来如此巨大。我不认为我们在计划行程时知道真正会发生什么。
The stewardess came over to us and said, we just got a message out of Panama City that you are going to be the first ones off the plane, so we want you to come up and sit in the front. So we went up to the front. And they asked us to give them our baggage tickets and things. Somebody was going to take care of all that business. And as soon as this door is opened on the plane--
空姐走过来对我们说，我们刚收到巴拿马城的通知，你们将是第一批下飞机的，所以我们希望你们去前面坐。于是我们去了前面。他们要求我们把行李票之类的东西交给他们。会有人处理这一切事务的。就在飞机舱门打开的那一刻——
We were whisked away by these people. This was really overwhelming to me, because I had been on an airplane all day. I just remember feeling really hazy about all this and kind of just letting myself get dragged along. And I just knew that I had to keep smiling because flashbulbs were going off everywhere and everyone was saying my name.
我们被这些人迅速带走。这对我来说真的很不知所措，因为我已经在飞机上坐了一整天。我只记得对这一切感到非常迷糊，只是任由自己被拖着走。我知道我必须保持微笑，因为到处都是闪光灯，每个人都在喊我的名字。
Throughout her entire trip, Sarah was appointed a personal videographer who documented her every move. The video starts as Sarah and her mother are hurried from the plane to a press conference, where Sarah meets the mayor of the city and is given a scroll proclaiming her a "Meritorious Daughter of Panama."
在整个行程中，莎拉被指派了一名私人摄像师，记录了她的一举一动。视频开始时，莎拉和她妈妈被匆匆从飞机带到一场新闻发布会上，莎拉在那里见到了市长，并被授予了一份卷轴，宣布她为“巴拿马功勋女儿”。
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
[西班牙语发言]
I declare Sarah York--
我宣布莎拉·约克——
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
[西班牙语发言]
--a great friend of--
——是一位伟大的朋友——
She's also given the key to the city, the second one ever presented to an American. The first one was given to Jimmy Carter. Panamanian and American reporters call out questions over the sound of cameras clicking.
她还被授予了城市钥匙，这是有史以来第二次颁发给美国人。第一次是颁给吉米·卡特的。巴拿马和美国的记者在相机的快门声中大声提问。
On the airplane, we asked the stewardess, how do you say "good evening"? Because I said, you gotta be able to-- you might have to make a statement, Sarah. And she's like, well, what am I going to say? And I said, well, we can maybe figure something out. And so this stewardess or flight attendant, told us that "buenas tardes" is "good evening," and so that's what Sarah managed to get out.
在飞机上，我们问空姐，怎么说“晚上好”？因为我说，你得能够——你可能需要发表声明，莎拉。她说，嗯，我该说什么？我说，好吧，我们可以想点办法。于是这位空姐告诉我们“buenas tardes”是“晚上好”，这就是莎拉设法说出来的。
Buenas tardes.
Buenas tardes（晚上好）。
Oh, she says buenas tardes.
哦，她说晚上好。
[CROWD LAUGHING]
[人群笑声]
In the video, Sarah can barely speak through the huge grin on her face. When she does talk, she takes deep breaths and speaks carefully. As the flashbulbs glint off her big, round glasses, she looks dazed and fragile.
在视频中，莎拉脸上带着灿烂的笑容，几乎说不出话来。当她说话时，她深吸一口气，小心翼翼地表达。当闪光灯从她大大的圆眼镜上反射出来时，她看起来神情恍惚且脆弱。
Aren't you going to tell him that you're happy that he invited you here?
你不想告诉他你很高兴他邀请你来这里吗？
Yeah. You can tell him that I'm happy that he invited me here, and I'm really excited to be here.
是的。你可以告诉他我很高兴他邀请我来这里，我真的很兴奋能到这里。
Tell them you're speechless.
告诉他们你无话可说了。
I'm just speechless.
我只是无话可说。
I just felt like such a celebrity. Everyone seemed like they knew me already. [LAUGHS] I was just-- I don't know. I was just really amazed, and felt really loved.
我感觉自己就像个名人。每个人似乎都已经认识我了。[笑]我只是——我不知道。我只是真的很惊讶，感到被爱。
What do you expect to see in Panama?
你期待在巴拿马看到什么？
Oh, they told me that I was going to see the Canal and that I was going to go to the fair, and go to see a couple of cities and meet a lot of people here.
哦，他们告诉我我将看到运河，我将去参加集市，去见几个城市的人，见到这里很多人。
[CAMERA SHUTTERS CLICKING]
[相机快门声]
Since they arrived late in the evening, they wouldn't meet the general until the next day. Their celebrity entry into Panama ended in a good night's sleep at a nice hotel.
由于他们深夜才到达，要到第二天才能见到将军。他们作为名人的巴拿马之行以在一家豪华酒店安稳睡了一觉告终。
In the morning, they were led by an entourage to the Defense Forces headquarters. The steps to the building were lined with soldiers in their uniforms at attention. When they reached the top of the steps, Noriega himself was there to greet them.
早晨，在一群随从的引领下，他们前往国防军总部。大楼的台阶两旁站满了身着制服、严阵以待的士兵。当他们到达台阶顶部时，诺列加本人就在那里迎接他们。
He was right there, and he put his hand right out and said, welcome. And he gave us each the traditional, you grab the hand and then you do the kiss on each cheek type thing. And he did that.
他就在那里，直接伸出手说，欢迎。他给了我们每个人传统的礼节，抓着手，然后在每边脸颊亲吻一下。他就是这么做的。
He looked just like he did on TV or in pictures. I knew who he was right away.
他看起来和电视或照片上的一模一样。我立刻就认出了他是谁。
First of all, we exchanged gifts. We brought him down a few things from Michigan. And that's when he gave Sarah a little Teddy bear in fatigues.
首先，我们交换了礼物。我们从密歇根带了一些东西给他。就在那时，他给了莎拉一只穿着迷彩服的小泰迪熊。
I think we brought him a snow globe that you shake. Just things that were different-- that we thought would be different to them.
我想我们带了一个摇一摇就会下雪的水晶球。就是一些不同的东西——我们觉得对他们来说会很新奇。
I thought he was this big guy. I mean, just from what you saw, I thought he was this hefty guy, and he wasn't. He was about my size. I'm not kidding. He's petite.
我以为他是个大块头。我是说，从你看到的画面来看，我以为他是个魁梧的男人，但他不是。他大概和我一样大。我没开玩笑。他很娇小。
But anyway, I made him this shirt. It was a khaki-colored thing. I made it like extra large, and I was sitting there going, man alive. I was really kind of embarrassed when I gave it to him. I said, well, maybe you can find somebody that this is going to fit. He held it up to him, and it was like a mile too big. But he said, it's very, very nice. Oh, you made this.
但总之，我给他做了这件衬衫。它是卡其色的。我把它做得特别大，我坐在那里心想，天哪。我给他时真的很尴尬。我说，好吧，也许你能找到能穿它的人。他把它举到身上，大得离谱。但他却说，它非常、非常漂亮。哦，这是你做的。
After we exchanged gifts, I said to him, we have a few questions. I said, would you mind answering a few questions for us? And he said, sure, ask me anything. And I said, if you don't want to answer anything, you just tell us, if we ask a question that you don't want to answer.
交换礼物后，我对他说，我们有几个问题。我说，您介意回答我们几个问题吗？他说，当然，问吧。我说，如果您不想回答什么，您就告诉我们，如果我们问的问题您不想回答。
We just started out with basic stuff, like when is your birthday? When were you born? And where were you born? And do you have brothers and sisters?
我们只是从基本的东西开始，比如你的生日是什么时候？你什么时候出生的？你在哪里出生的？你有兄弟姐妹吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
[西班牙语发言]
Three older brothers.
三个哥哥。
You're the baby?
你是最小的？
Yes.
是的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He was just really friendly and really smiley and almost just as much as his letters-- very formal and kind, but not super personal.
他真的很友好，总是带着微笑，和他的信里差不多——非常正式和客气，但不是特别私密。
If you could vote in the upcoming US presidential election, who would you vote for?
如果您能在即将到来的美国总统大选中投票，您会投给谁？
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
[西班牙语发言]
Oh! Yeah, right. If he was going to vote, he would vote for you.
哦！是的，当然。如果他要投票，他会投给你。
But then finally, we got into some things about the Panama Canal. I don't think we ever asked him any questions about drugs and drug trafficking. We just didn't. We had read enough of that kind of thing. But I didn't really say, are you guilty or not?
但最后，我们谈到了一些关于巴拿马运河的事情。我想我们从没问过他任何关于毒品和贩毒的问题。我们就是没问。我们已经读过足够多这类东西了。但我真的没问，你有罪还是没罪？
The next days would be spent touring the city and then the country, meeting Noriega's family and other Panamanians-- people that had been appointed to show Sarah around, but also people from all over the countryside, even hours away, who had come just to meet her and bring her gifts.
接下来的几天，他们参观了城市和国家，见到了诺列加的家人和其他巴拿马人——那些被指派带领莎拉参观的人，还有从全国各地来的人，甚至有远道而来，只为了见她一面并给她带礼物的。
Sarah and her mom saw the tourists sites, but they also went a little off the beaten path to a poor neighborhood where Noriega grew up and to a village outside of Panama City. In every place that Sarah went, she was given gifts, and introduced to children her age. She traded friendship bracelets-- also a craze among the youth of Panama at that time-- and took in words of Spanish. And she even learned to dance.
莎拉和她妈妈参观了旅游景点，但他们也去了一些偏远的地方，包括诺列加长大的贫民区和巴拿马城外的一个村庄。莎拉所到之处，都会收到礼物，并被介绍给和她同龄的孩子。她交换了友谊手环——在当时的巴拿马青少年中也很流行——并学习了一些西班牙语单词。她甚至学会了跳舞。
She saw Noriega here and there when he had time, but mostly she was sent off to see as much of the country as she could. And wherever she went, the press followed her. While on American news every night, there was talk of Noriega and his oppressive regime, on the Panamanian news, there was a full report of where Sarah had gone, and what she had done that day.
她有空时会见到诺列加，但大部分时间她被送去参观尽可能多的地方。无论她走到哪里，媒体都跟着她。当美国每晚的新闻里都在谈论诺列加及其压迫性政权时，巴拿马的新闻里却完整报道了莎拉去了哪里，那天做了什么。
I tried to be really polite, but I definitely tried to give the cold shoulder to people who I felt were being impolite to me. It was hard sometimes just to be in the spotlight all the time, too. There was photographers following us around constantly.
我尽量表现得非常有礼貌，但我绝对会对那些我觉得对我没礼貌的人冷眼相待。一直处于聚光灯下有时也很难。总有摄影师跟着我们。
There's a series of photographs that Sarah's mom showed me that I keep thinking about because, in them, Sarah seems so small and literally tossed around in a very strange setting. They were taken at Noriega's beach house. Sarah's mom is inside with the adults. Sarah is swimming with Noriega's young daughter and her friend. But the water's pretty rough. There are big waves.
莎拉的妈妈给我看了几张照片，我一直在想，因为照片里的莎拉看起来那么小，简直被丢进了一个非常陌生的地方。它们是在诺列加的海滨别墅拍的。莎拉的妈妈在里面和成年人们在一起。莎拉正和诺列加年幼的女儿及其朋友游泳。但水流相当急。有很大的海浪。
And then here, she got knocked down. And once you're down in that kind of water, it's hard to get your bearings and get back up again before another wave hits you. And she was kind of getting flipped around by this wave. She's got one leg up in the air, and she looks like she's punching herself in the face there. It looks like just a lot of water flying around.
然后就在这儿，她被冲倒了。一旦你在那种水里倒下，就很难找回重心，在下一个浪打来之前站起来。她被海浪翻来覆去地冲。她的一条腿高高翘在空中，看起来像是在给自己脸上来了一拳。看起来到处都是飞溅的水花。
The next photo shows a wave crashing down on Sarah's head and, at the edge of the frame, the arm and leg of someone on shore running to help her. In the last picture, General Noriega is wrapping a towel around Sarah, his shirt soaked with water, a worried look on his face, ushering her towards drier ground. He doesn't look like a ruthless dictator or a drug kingpin. He just looks like someone's dad.
下一张照片显示一个海浪拍打在莎拉的头上，在画面边缘，岸上有人跑过来救她。在最后一张照片中，诺列加将军正在给莎拉裹上毛巾，他的衬衫被水浸透了，脸上带着担忧的神情，引导她走向干地。他看起来不像一个残暴的独裁者或毒枭。他看起来就像某人的爸爸。
What was it like to go back home?
回到家感觉怎么样？
It was almost as much of a shock as going there. When I came home, it was freezing, and of course I had felt like, oh, I've accustomed to this tropical climate now. [CHUCKLES] And there was kids from my class waiting for me at the airport. I felt like a total celebrity.
这几乎和去那里一样令人震惊。当我回到家时，天气冷得要命，当然我当时觉得，哦，我已经习惯了这个热带气候。[笑]我班上的孩子们在机场等着我。我感觉自己像个十足的名人。
Sarah York finished up the research for her two-page report on Panama this week. That followed a nearly week-long visit to the Central American country as a guest of General Manuel Noriega. If grades were given by the enthusiasm of teachers, school officials, and nearly 450 students, then Sarah could easily get an A-triple-plus.
莎拉·约克本周完成了她那篇关于巴拿马的两页报告的研究。此前，她作为诺列加将军的客人，对这个中美洲国家进行了近一周的访问。如果分数是由老师、学校官员和近450名学生的热情程度来决定，那么莎拉很容易得到A+++。
She created a bond of friendship between the people of Panama and the students of this school district. The school board has proclaimed tomorrow, October 14, as Sarah York Day in the Negaunee Public Schools.
她在巴拿马人民和本学区的学生之间建立了一条友谊纽带。校董会宣布明天，10月14日，为尼高尼公立学校的“莎拉·约克日”。
Right away when I got back, we started putting together a slideshow of pictures that we had taken. And I went to a lot of classes in different schools, and I went and talked to the ladies' club at some church. [CHUCKLES] I felt pretty important. But it wasn't long before we started hearing more negative stuff, too.
我一回来，我们就开始整理我们拍摄的照片幻灯片。我去很多学校参加了不同的班级，我还去了某个教堂的女士俱乐部谈话。[笑]我感觉自己挺重要的。但没过多久，我们也开始听到更多负面的声音。
Coming up, the negative stuff arrives, permanently and irrevocably, as negative stuff can do sometimes. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
稍后，负面的声音来了，正如负面的事情有时会发生的那样，是永久且不可逆转的。芝加哥公共广播电台的节目稍后继续，我们只需一分钟。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. As you may have heard, Manuel Noriega died last week at 83. And when we heard the news around here at our program, it made a bunch of us remember this old show that we did back in 2003. Andrea Morningstar's story about Sarah York from the town of Negaunee, Michigan, who, at the age of 10, befriended and then visited this man who was considered an enemy of the United States.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。你可能已经听说了，曼努埃尔·诺列加上周去世了，享年83岁。当我们在节目组听到这个消息时，让我们许多人想起了我们2003年制作的这个旧节目。安德烈娅·莫宁斯塔关于密歇根州尼高尼镇莎拉·约克的故事，她在10岁时与这个被视为美国敌人的人交了朋友，并随后去探望了他。
At this point in our story, Sarah has just returned from her trip, and the American public, the American government, and American media are not too pleased with her.
在我们故事的这一部分，莎拉刚从旅途中回来，而美国公众、美国政府和美国媒体对她并不怎么高兴。
I guess it was pretty controversial that I accepted the invitation. And a lot of people said, you know, it was fine that she was writing to him, but why would she have to accept this invitation? Or, I wouldn't let my daughter go.
我想我接受邀请这件事挺有争议的。很多人说，你知道，她给他写信没关系，但为什么非要接受这个邀请？或者，我才不会让我女儿去呢。
I think they thought that my family was foolish for having this friendship, and that we were just getting ourselves into a bad situation. I think they just felt like it was unpatriotic. There was a lot of nastiness out there.
我想他们认为我的家庭因为这种友谊而变得愚蠢，我们只是让自己陷入了糟糕的境地。我想他们只是觉得这不爱国。外界有很多恶言恶语。
They got phone calls and letters from strangers. There were articles in newspapers all over the country and all over the world. Everyone had an opinion. The Guardian in London ridiculed Sarah and called her "the bespectacled infant" and "the white-socked, short-frocked Pollyanna."
他们接到了陌生人的电话和信件。全国乃至全世界的报纸上都有文章。每个人都有自己的看法。伦敦的《卫报》嘲讽莎拉，称她为“戴眼镜的婴儿”和“穿白袜子、短裙的波莉安娜”。
This is interesting. I wonder if you could read this.
这很有趣。我想知道你能不能读读这个。
Yeah. OK. What's this one here? Oh. Every Sunday in our local newspaper, they have what they call Voices of Superiorland. Someone goes out into the community and asks a key question of what's happening currently in the world. In this particular Voices of Superiorland, it says, "do you think Sarah York should have gone to Panama to visit with General Noriega?"
好的。那这一条呢？哦。每个星期天在我们的当地报纸上，他们都有所谓的“苏必利尔之地之声”。有人会走到社区里，询问目前世界上发生的事情中的一个关键问题。在这一期的《苏必利尔之地之声》中，它写道：“你认为莎拉·约克应该去巴拿马拜访诺列加将军吗？”
This guy says-- he's from the Air Force. There used to be an Air Force base here. And he says, "I think it's a risky move." And then there was another woman. She was from Negaunee. "I'm suspicious of Noriega's motives to invite her there." Here's another one. "No, it's just too much military activity." Another one here. "No, I think it's too dangerous for her. It's a scary part of the world." "No, it's obvious that she's being used." And another one. "No, Noriega still is under drug investigation."
这个人说——他来自空军。这里过去有个空军基地。他说：“我认为这是个冒险的举动。”然后还有另一位女士。她来自尼高尼。“我怀疑诺列加邀请她去那里的动机。”这是另一条。“不，太多的军事活动了。”这里还有一条。“不，我觉得这对她太危险了。那是世界上一个可怕的地方。”“不，很明显她被利用了。”还有另一条。“不，诺列加还在接受毒品调查。”
And then here's one other guy. This guy says, "Sure, why not? It's a free country. She should be able to go there if she wants." So two out of the 10 said yeah, this is all right, and the rest of them were like, no, no, no.
还有最后一个人。这个人说：“当然，为什么不呢？这是一个自由国家。如果她愿意，她应该能去那里。”所以10个人里有两人说可以，这没问题，而其余的人都说，不，不，不。
Sarah's friendship with a man who has been described as a drug runner and is under indictment here in the United States has drawn some criticism, including that of Northern Michigan's congressman.
莎拉与一个被描述为毒贩、在美国受到起诉的人之间的友谊引发了一些批评，包括来自密歇根州北部议员的批评。
I think what happens is it kind of gives Noriega the opportunity to be able to take advantage of that situation and use it as a propaganda tool.
我认为发生的事情是，它让诺列加有机会利用这种情况，并将其作为宣传工具。
But Sarah's father says if she has been used at all, it has not been for propaganda purposes.
但莎拉的父亲说，如果她真的被利用了，那也不是为了宣传目的。
I wouldn't call it propaganda.
我不会称之为宣传。
What would you call it?
那你会称它为什么？
A symbol. She's been used as a symbol of friendship between the two countries.
一个象征。她被用作两国之间友谊的象征。
I remember being in middle school and getting a phone call from a radio station. I think it was set up beforehand that I was going to do this interview, like a live radio show. And I took the call in the principal's office. And they left me alone in his office so I could use the phone and have some privacy.
我记得在读中学时接到过电台的电话。我想这是提前安排好的，我要接受采访，就像现场直播的广播节目一样。我在校长的办公室接了电话。他们让我独自在办公室里，这样我可以用电话并保持私密性。
I think usually when I'd talk on the phone to a reporter, my mom or dad would be maybe just in the other room or listening, just to make sure things were going good and everything, but I was totally on my own this time.
我想通常我接受记者采访时，我妈妈或爸爸可能就在隔壁房间或者在听着，只是为了确保一切顺利，但我这次完全是一个人。
It started out like a normal interview, and then the guy got totally nasty and started saying all this stuff that brought me to tears, and I was just crying and I couldn't respond. He was saying things like, "Do you know that Noriega rapes girls your age?" and things like that. And I was just like-- I couldn't believe that he would have the gall to say that to like an 11- or 12-year-old girl, and that his listeners would think that was OK.
采访开始时很正常，然后那个人变得极其恶毒，开始说所有那些让我泪流满面的话，我只是在哭，无法回应。他说着这样的话，“你知道诺列加会强奸你这个年纪的女孩吗？”之类的话。我当时就想——我简直不敢相信他竟然有脸对一个11或12岁的女孩说这种话，而且他的听众会认为这没问题。
I really wish I would have been able to tell him off on the air. It was a live show. If he was doing that to me, I really wish I could have come back with something, or just hung up on him. And instead, I was too polite. I didn't even hang up. I stayed on the stupid line and I was crying on the radio.
我真的很希望我当时能在广播里反驳他。那是现场直播。如果他那样对我，我真希望我能回击他，或者直接挂掉他的电话。而相反，我太有礼貌了。我甚至没挂掉。我一直守在那条该死的线上，在广播里哭泣。
Among the things that Sarah was given was a letter from Noriega that he had written while she was visiting and intended for her to read when she got back home. In the letter, he gives her a kind of kid-sized diplomatic mission.
在莎拉收到的东西中，有一封诺列加在访问期间写的信，打算让她回家后读。在信中，他给了她一种孩子规模的外交使命。
"Dear Sarah, when I invited you to visit my country, Panama, I did it only for the intelligence and curiosity that you had about Panama, never with the intention of political or propaganda overtones. The United States and Panama have had common interests since 1903, and never in our territory has there existed any hate or aggression toward the North American people.
“亲爱的莎拉，当我邀请你访问我的国家巴拿马时，这完全是出于你对巴拿马的智慧和好奇心，绝没有任何政治或宣传的弦外之音。美国和巴拿马自1903年以来就有共同利益，在我们的领土上，从来没有任何对北美人民的仇恨或侵略。”
The American people have an interest in knowing our children and our ethnic groups. I was interested that you should see our poor and not just the pretty, coquettish things. I was also interested that you should be free to move around, question, and walk our streets. I was interested that you should see our children and play with them, and see that they have need of help and protection of the government and its leaders.
“美国人民有兴趣了解我们的孩子和我们的民族。我有兴趣让你看到我们的穷人，而不只是那些漂亮、做作的东西。我也有兴趣让你自由地走动、提问并走过我们的街道。我有兴趣让你看看我们的孩子，和他们一起玩耍，并看到他们需要政府及其领导人的帮助和保护。”
The government and leaders of Panama have not yet done everything in order that there would be fewer hungry children, without schools, shelter, and food, but I continue fighting for the children that are the future of all the countries of the world. Your visit to Panama demonstrates that the children and peoples separate from the government and their advisers speak the same language, which is that of love, friendship, and peace.
“巴拿马的政府和领导人尚未完成一切工作，以使那些饥饿的孩子减少，不再没有学校、住所和食物，但我继续为那些是世界各国未来的孩子们战斗。你对巴拿马的访问证明了，那些脱离政府及其顾问的孩子和人民说的是同一种语言，那就是爱、友谊与和平。”
I ask that, when you return to Negaunee, that you say that you met men, women, children, old people, government officials, and soldiers who want to live in peace. That they don't want war.
“我请求你，当你回到尼高尼时，要说你见到了想生活在和平中的男人、女人、孩子、老人、政府官员和士兵。他们不想要战争。”
God protect you. And from today on, I solemnly invite you so that, in the year 1999, at 12:00 noon, December 31, you will be at the bridge of the Americas to cut the ribbon of Panama."
“上帝保佑你。从今天起，我郑重邀请你，以便在1999年12月31日中午12点，你能在美洲大桥上剪下巴拿马的彩带。”
This is huge. The ceremony he's talking about is the day when the canal would finally be handed over to the Panamanians.
这太大了。他谈论的仪式是运河最终移交给巴拿马人的那一天。
"May you have a good trip. I send greetings to your father, Mitchell; to your brother, Carl; to your brother, Caleb; to your neighbors; to your teachers; to your friends; and to the man who runs the only gas station in town, Francis. Greetings to the principal, Mr. Robert Trevilcock. The next time, you will also be invited to Panama.
“祝你旅途愉快。我向你的父亲米切尔；你的兄弟卡尔；你的兄弟凯莱布；你的邻居们；你的老师们；你的朋友们；以及镇上唯一经营加油站的人弗朗西斯致意。向校长罗伯特·特雷维尔科克先生致意。下次，你还会被邀请到巴拿马。”
Sarah, I have come to know much about your people and friends. Therefore, I congratulate you for being so brave in talking with such emotion about them. Sarah, I'm not going to say goodbye, just see you later. Peace is from God, and therefore, it is welcome to whichever part of the world that will have it.
“莎拉，我已经很了解你的人民和朋友了。因此，我祝贺你如此勇敢地充满感情地谈论他们。莎拉，我不说再见，只说一会儿见。和平来自上帝，因此，它欢迎任何愿意接受它的世界部分。”
Today, October 10, happy birthday, and on the 14th, when you celebrate it in Michigan.
“今天，10月10日，生日快乐，在14日，当你在密歇根庆祝时。”
Your friend, General Manuel Antonio Noriega.
“你的朋友，曼努埃尔·安东尼奥·诺列加将军。”
P.S. My wife, Felicidad, joins me with my words and wishes to give you a mother's kiss that would tie you to the tears, laughter, struggle, and work for the children of Panama."
“附：我的妻子费利西达德加入我的话语，愿给你一个母亲的吻，这将让你与巴拿马孩子们的泪水、欢笑、奋斗和劳动联系在一起。”
Wow. He was a much better letter-writer than me. I think this is a great letter. [CHUCKLES] Yeah. And I really took that to heart when I got it, too.
哇。他比我更会写信。我觉得这是一封很棒的信。[笑]是的。当我收到它时，我也真的把它记在心里了。
Once I went, I couldn't really back down anymore. I think that Noriega and the people in Panama felt like, OK, now you've come here. We brought you here. You just took on a job. You have to be our spokesperson, and you have to learn as much as you can about this and kind of educate Americans, because our country's at stake.
一旦我去了，我就真的不能退缩了。我觉得诺列加和巴拿马人民觉得，好吧，现在你已经来这了。我们把你带到这。你刚刚承担了一份工作。你必须成为我们的发言人，你必须尽可能多地了解这一切，并教育美国人，因为我们的国家危在旦夕。
So I guess, in a way, after I got back, it was like I had a job. And that sounds kind of naive and simple-minded, maybe, now, but I just met a whole bunch of people in this country and I didn't want to see our country attack them. I didn't want to see us go in and kill or whatever this new friend I had, either. To me, he just seemed like a reasonable guy.
所以我猜，在某种程度上，我回来后，就像有了一份工作。这现在听起来可能有点天真和头脑简单，但我只是在那个国家见到了很多人，我不希望看到我们的国家攻击他们。我也不希望看到我们进去杀死或什么的这个我新交的朋友。对我来说，他看起来只是个讲道理的人。
In retrospect, I look at the newspaper articles and the quotes, and people were just interested in what a demon Noriega was, and how could I be friends with him? And I would defend him, and it sounds really naive now when I read these articles. "Oh, he's a really nice guy." [CHUCKLES] I'd say things like that. But people would just take my story or my words and twist them around, turn it into something sensationalist.
回想起来，我看看报纸文章和引语，人们只是对诺列加是个什么样的恶魔，以及我怎么能和他成为朋友感兴趣？我会为他辩护，现在读这些文章听起来真的很天真。“哦，他是个很好的人。”[笑]我会说那样的话。但人们只会拿着我的故事或我的话断章取义，把它变成耸人听闻的东西。
I wish I could have been more articulate then, because I think my message came across as really unrealistic and brainwashed. I feel like there must have been a way for me to get my message out without sounding so stupid, but what do you expect from an 11-year-old? [CHUCKLES] I don't know if there's any way I could have done a better job.
我真希望当时我能表达得更清楚，因为我觉得我传达的信息听起来真的很不现实而且像是被洗脑了。我觉得肯定有一种方式能让我传达我的信息而不至于听起来那么愚蠢，但你对一个11岁的孩子有什么期望呢？[笑]我不知道我是否能做得更好。
The closer the US came to an invasion, the clearer it became that Sarah and her family couldn't do anything to stop it. It was December 20, 1989, late at night, when the first US troops were parachuted into combat, and took over the Torrijos International Airport.
美国越接近入侵，就越清楚莎拉和她的家人无法做任何事情来阻止它。那是1989年12月20日深夜，第一批美国军队空降到战场，接管了托里霍斯国际机场。
The Yorks were in bed when they started getting calls. Pauline's brother called first to tell her the news, and then reporters started calling. A friend at a local news station helped them issue a message to the media to leave them alone. They watched live news feeds from a neighbor's house who had a satellite dish. Around 4:00 AM, they went home to try and get some sleep. It was the first full day of the invasion.
约克一家在床上时就开始接到电话。波琳的兄弟先打电话告诉她这个消息，然后记者开始打电话。当地一家新闻台的朋友帮助他们向媒体发布了一条消息，让他们别打扰他们。他们在一个有卫星天线的朋友家里观看新闻直播。凌晨4点左右，他们回家试图睡一会儿。那是入侵的第一整天。
In the early hours of the morning, they got a call from Thais, one of Noriega's secretaries that they had become close to while they were there.
凌晨时分，他们接到了泰斯的电话，她是诺列加的一位秘书，他们在那里时曾与她变得亲近。
She called me and she says, "Pauline!" She says, "you have to do something." She said, "we've got people that are shot and they need to get to the hospital, and they won't let us through the streets. They won't let the ambulances go through the streets." And I'm helpless. What could I do for her? But she was in a desperate situation. I don't think she knew who else to call in the United States that was their friend. I mean, who was she going to call, the president? Is she going to call a congressman? She didn't have those kind of connections. I just felt so helpless.
她打电话给我说，“波琳！”她说，“你必须做点什么。”她说，“我们有人中弹了，他们需要去医院，但他们不让我们通过街道。他们不让救护车通过街道。”我很无助。我能为她做什么呢？但她正处于绝望的境地。我想她不知道在美国还能给谁打电话，谁是他们的朋友。我是说，她要打给谁，总统？她要打给国会议员？她没有那种关系。我感到如此无助。
They watched in horror as the US continued to invade Panama. Buildings were being bombed that Sarah and her mother recognized and had even been to. The neighborhood where Noriega grew up was bombed, too, and Sarah wondered about the safety of the kids she had met there.
他们惊恐地看着美国继续入侵巴拿马。莎拉和她妈妈认出的、甚至去过的建筑物被炸毁。诺列加长大的社区也被轰炸了，莎拉担心她在那里遇过的孩子们的安全。
Conservative estimates say around 200 Panamanian civilians died in the invasion with thousands wounded. 26 Americans died.
保守估计，入侵中有约200名巴拿马平民死亡，数千人受伤。26名美国人死亡。
A US Psychological Operations battalion surrounded the Vatican embassy, where Noriega was taking refuge, and blared rock music all day and night. Finally, after days of this, Noriega surrendered and was taken to a federal prison in Miami, and convicted of drug trafficking and money laundering.
一个美国心理作战营包围了诺列加寻求庇护的梵蒂冈大使馆，日夜不停地播放摇滚乐。终于，在经过几天这样之后，诺列加投降并被带到迈阿密的一个联邦监狱，被判犯有贩毒和洗钱罪。
Although it was one of the most expensive drug cases ever prosecuted, and although the US searched for proof of Noriega's wrongdoing after they invaded, they found very little and had a hard time proving their case. The US ended up relying on circumstantial evidence and testimony from convicted drug traffickers.
尽管这是有史以来最昂贵的毒品案件之一，尽管美国在入侵后寻找诺列加罪行的证据，但他们发现的东西很少，且很难证明他们的案子。美国最终依赖于间接证据和被定罪毒贩的证词。
Afterwards, Noriega's lawyer, Frank Rubino, said he was alarmed at the way the first Bush administration invaded Panama and went after Noriega. He declared, quote, "The United States will not trample across the entire world, imposing its will upon so-called independent, sovereign nations. Unless leaders of foreign governments are willing to kneel once a day and face Washington and give grace to George Bush, they, too, may be in the same posture as General Noriega."
事后，诺列加的律师弗兰克·鲁比诺表示，他对老布什政府入侵巴拿马并追击诺列加的方式感到震惊。他宣称：“美国将不会践踏整个世界，将自己的意志强加于所谓的独立主权国家。除非外国政府领导人愿意每天跪下一次，面向华盛顿，并为乔治·布什祈祷，否则他们也可能处于和诺列加将军一样的处境。”
During this time, Sarah continued her correspondence with him. She even visited him and his family during his trial in Florida. But it became more and more difficult to sit down and write the letters. She was a teenager, getting into teenager things, and she had never had a friend in prison before. She became less interested in the correspondence, and her folks kind of took over, sometimes dictating what it was she said in the letters.
在此期间，莎拉继续与他保持通信。她甚至在他佛罗里达受审期间探望过他和他的家人。但坐下来写信变得越来越困难。她是个青少年，开始搞青少年的事情，而且她以前从没交过在监狱里的朋友。她对通信的兴趣减弱了，她的家人们某种程度上接手了，有时甚至口述了她在信中说的话。
I think it got just too confusing for me, and I think it was just easier for me to kind of ignore a lot of what was going on. I don't know. You don't know what to say. It's like, can you imagine a young teenager writing to you in prison? What would they say? Or how would they try to make you-- how would they be able to make you feel better?
我想这对我来说太困惑了，我觉得忽略正在发生的很多事情对我来说更容易。我不知道。你不知道该说什么。就像，你能想象一个年轻的青少年给你写信吗？他们会说什么？或者他们如何能试着让你——他们如何能让你感觉好点？
So what was your concern? You wanted to make him feel better?
所以你担心什么？你想让他感觉好点？
I guess so. And just to let him know that we were standing behind him and supporting him, and that we were still friends. But I just didn't really know how to do that.
我想是的。只是让他知道我们支持他，并且我们仍然是朋友。但我真的不知道该怎么做。
When we talk about the story, Sarah says that she isn't sure how that experience fits in with the rest of her life. The life she's living now seems really far away from that, and she rarely speaks about Noriega anymore.
当我们谈论这个故事时，莎拉说她不确定那段经历如何融入她生活的其余部分。她现在过的生活似乎离那个很遥远，她也很少再谈论诺列加了。
She and her husband and baby are living completely off the grid in the woods of Northern Wisconsin. No electricity or running water. You take a county road to another county road and then a dirt road with no name, and eventually, you'll find their canvas tent.
她和丈夫以及孩子完全脱离社会，住在威斯康星州北部的森林里。没有电或自来水。你要经过一条县道到另一条县道，然后是一条没有名字的土路，最终你会找到他们的帆布帐篷。
There's a lot to do here. They make everything they can from scratch. Haul their own water, clean their own diapers. And they're building their own house, which they want to get done before Sarah delivers their second child and the winter sets in.
这里有很多事情要做。他们尽可能从零开始做每一件事。自己运水，自己洗尿布。他们正在建自己的房子，他们想在莎拉生下第二个孩子和冬天来临之前完工。
I asked Sarah if she thinks that the whole experience with Noriega has anything to do with her choice to live this way, and she kind of shrugs. She doesn't make that connection. When Sarah was 11, when she was thrust into the international spotlight and her world got so much bigger, it also spun a little out of control. Suddenly, she had things she felt she needed to say but didn't know how to, and everything seemed to get twisted around.
我问莎拉，她是否认为与诺列加的整个经历与她选择这样生活有任何关系，她耸了耸肩。她没有建立那种联系。当莎拉11岁时，当她被推向国际聚光灯下，她的世界变得如此广阔，它也变得有些失控。突然，她有了她觉得需要说却不知道如何说的话，一切似乎都变得扭曲了。
Something you can say about her life now is that there's not much chance of that. She's in control of everything, from the food she feeds her family to the electricity she doesn't use. She lives as responsibly as she knows how. There's no room for misinterpretation.
关于她现在的生活，你可以说的一点是，这种情况不太可能发生了。她掌控着一切，从她喂养家人的食物到她不使用的电力。她尽可能负责任地生活。没有误解的空间。
Andrea Morningstar. She's a filmmaker currently making a documentary about a school in Detroit.
安德烈娅·莫宁斯塔。她是一位电影制片人，目前正在制作一部关于底特律一所学校的纪录片。
Since we first ran this story in 2003, Sarah has moved from her home off the grid to the Twin Cities, where she works as a Spanish teacher and plays in the bands The Wild Goose Chase Cloggers and Hello, Heartache.
自2003年我们首次播出这个故事以来，莎拉已经从她远离社会的家搬到了双子城，她在那里担任西班牙语老师，并在乐队“野鹅追逐伐木工”和“你好，心痛”中演奏。
As for General Manuel Noriega, after serving his sentence in the United States, he was extradited to France and then back to Panama in 2011. He died last week after complications after brain surgery. In March, right before his surgery, Sarah's mom, Pauline, went to visit him. She brought him a letter from Sarah.
至于曼努埃尔·诺列加将军，在美国服刑后，他被引渡到法国，然后在2011年回到巴拿马。他上周在脑部手术后出现了并发症而去世。在3月，就在他手术前，莎拉的妈妈波琳去探望了他。她带给他一封莎拉的信。
Act Two, Pen Pal Husband.
第二幕，笔友丈夫。
Janice met and married Nate Powell in 1972. He was a romantic and gentle man, except when he drank. He was kind of a mean drunk. He'd get angry, full of rage. A few years into their marriage, Nate was arrested for robbing a utility company, and he was sent to prison for eight years. Janice holds dear the memory of those years, including the letters that she got from Nate when he was in prison.
贾妮丝在1972年与内特·鲍威尔相识并结婚。他是个浪漫温柔的人，除了喝醉酒的时候。他喝醉了有点刻薄。他会生气，充满愤怒。结婚几年后，内特因抢劫一家公用事业公司被捕，并被送入监狱服刑八年。贾妮丝珍藏着那些年的记忆，包括内特在监狱时写给她的信。
The relationship just enriched so much. It just blossomed. I received a letter every day. Every day.
关系真的丰富了许多。它简直蓬勃发展。我每天都收到一封信。每天。
He was a nonstop talker. I called him Mr. Et Cetera because he talked on and on and on and on. Initially, when he first went to jail, I read all his letters over and over. But then they started coming so frequent and every day, and four and five pages and all on legal paper, I just didn't read them over.
他是个不停的谈话者。我叫他“等等先生”，因为他总是没完没了地说。起初，他刚入狱时，我一遍又一遍地读他的信。但后来它们开始变得如此频繁，每天都有，四五页长，全写在法律用纸上，我就没再通读了。
"If I had money when we met, I would have brought you the best of everything and taken you around the world. Even though I was a sinner, I had the desire to give you every pleasure that you had ever dreamed about having." That's-- that's another X-rated bit.
“如果我们相遇时我有钱，我会带给你最好的一切，带你周游世界。尽管我曾是个罪人，但我曾渴望给你你梦寐以求的所有快乐。”那是——那是另一段限制级的话。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
Our phone bill at one point went up to like $800. We would talk on the phone, because the inmates, they had a certain time that they could call, and they were limited to so many minutes. But if there was no one else in line to make phone calls, then you could talk as long as you want to. And Nate had such a charm and a charisma about him that sometimes the guards would come and get him. They said, Mr. Powell, there's no one in line to use the phone if you want to call your wife.
我们的电话费一度高达800美元。我们会在电话里聊，因为囚犯们有固定的打电话时间，而且他们被限制了分钟数。但如果没有人排队等候打电话，那你就可以聊多久都行。内特有着如此的魅力和风度，以至于有时狱警会来找他。他们说，鲍威尔先生，如果没有人排队等候用电话，你可以打电话给你妻子。
Every now and then, he would have an opportunity to call me at work. "Hey, baby." And I said, oh god, this is great. You have made my day.
每隔一段时间，他就有机会在我工作时给我打电话。“嘿，宝贝。”我说，天哪，太棒了。你让我这天过得太美好了。
"Thinking of you and the joy I feel in having you as my woman is a delight on a day-to-day basis in itself--"
“想念你，把你当作我的女人让我感到的喜悦，这本身就是每一天的快乐——”
I had the craving. I had to see him. When he was sent to the road camps, I was not supposed to meet him, but this was something that we did. He was able to know where he would be. And sometimes, after he would get to that location, because he was outside, there may be a restaurant or a phone there on the corner, and he would have some change or something, and he'd call me. He'd say, baby, I'm down the street from your job. Can you run down here for a minute? Or, I'm going to be at-- tomorrow. You think you'll be able to come out there?
我有渴望。我必须见到他。当他被送到道路营地时，我本来不应该见他，但这是我们做过的事情。他能知道他会在哪里。有时，在他到达那个地点后，因为他在户外，拐角处可能有一家餐厅或一部电话，他会有零钱什么的，他会打电话给我。他说，宝贝，我就在你工作地点下的街上。你能跑过来一下吗？或者，我明天会在——你觉得你能出来吗？
I would always bring whatever I could, and I would leave stuff in the woods. Whatever it was he wanted me to leave for him-- if it was beer, bring a sandwich, a shirt, or whatever. It's over there by that tree. Did you see me when I passed by that tree? Well, it's right there.
我总是带去我能带的所有东西，我会把东西留在树林里。无论他想让我留给他什么——如果是啤酒，带个三明治、一件衬衫什么的。就在那棵树旁边。我经过那棵树时你看到我了吗？嗯，就在那儿。
Or either I'd just stand there and talk to him like just somebody walking down the highway. I'd talk to him. "Hey, baby, you sure do look good, man. I'm telling you." Things like that, yeah.
或者我只是站在那里和他说话，就像在大街上走路的人一样。我会和他聊天。“嘿，宝贝，你看起来真棒。真的。”诸如此类，是的。
Whenever he was working with the Bureau of Sanitation, he was the maintenance man. So the crew would go out, but they would leave him at the office. Well, they had a fence. It was like 8, 10 feet. I didn't know how to climb a fence. And he'd talk about, you mean to tell me you don't how to climb a fence? That don't make sense! So he would give me some gloves, and he would show me how to climb a fence. And I would have a picnic basket with a blanket in there, and I would have drinks and glasses. And we would go up in the woods and we'd lay down in the woods. It was just like we were at home.
每当他在环境卫生局工作时，他是维修工。所以工作人员会出去，但他们会把他留在办公室。嗯，他们有一道栅栏。大概8、10英尺高。我不知道怎么翻墙。他说，你是说你不知道怎么翻墙？这没道理！于是他会给我一些手套，然后教我怎么翻墙。我会带着一个装有毯子的野餐篮，我会带着饮料和杯子。我们会去树林里，躺在树林里。就像我们在家里一样。
I had bought him a cassette player and I brought tapes. And plus, he would make tapes and he would bring them out to the picnic area whenever we would have our lunch, and we would play them. Sometimes we would dance. He liked blues. And there's a different dance that you do when you're dancing to blues. It's sort of like a dirty dancing. Or we would listen to Nancy Wilson. That's one of those two-step things, and I really liked that, because his arms was always all around me and everything like we were the only ones there.
我给他买了一个卡带播放器，我还带了磁带。而且，他会录磁带，每当我们吃午饭时，他会把它们带到野餐区，我们会播放它们。有时我们会跳舞。他喜欢蓝调。跳蓝调时你的舞步是不一样的。有点像肮脏舞。或者我们会听南希·威尔逊的歌。那是那种两步舞之一，我真的很喜欢，因为他的双臂总是环绕着我，一切就像只有我们两个人一样。
[MUSIC - "HE'S MY GUY" BY NANCY WILSON]
[音乐 - 南希·威尔逊的“他是我的男人”]
Those eight years that Nate was in prison, those were precious to me. [LAUGHS] And I have six boxes of letters because he wrote me every day. Every day. I mean, big boxes. In some of the letters, he would tell me-- he'd say, oh, I had a dream about you last night and oh god, it was just great and things like that.
内特在监狱的那八年，对我来说非常珍贵。[笑]我有六箱信，因为他每天都给我写信。每天。我的意思是，大箱子。在一些信中，他会告诉我——他说，哦，我昨晚梦见你了，哦天哪，太棒了，诸如此类。
It was a positiveness that came out of the eight years because my husband had not graduated from high school, so he got his GED. And he's president of Alcohol Anonymous. And it enhanced him.
那是八年中产生的积极结果，因为我的丈夫没从高中毕业，所以他拿到了同等学力证书（GED）。他还是戒酒匿名协会的主席。这提升了他。
After the eight years-- this was in the back of my mind. I said, Nate. I said, do you think that you're going to revert back to how you were before you came here. He said, oh no! There's just no way. And when he got out of prison, he started drinking again. It was just the same Nate.
八年之后——这在我脑海里。我说，内特。我说，你觉得你会恢复到你来这之前那样吗？他说，哦不！绝不可能。当他出狱后，他又开始喝酒了。他还是那个内特。
When he was drinking, it was like Dr. Jekyll and Mr. Hyde. He was on that binge. It was like, I hated to come home, because this other person was there. He would get violent. And I'd have to go in my bedroom and board up the door, push the dresser in front of it and anything else, and sit on it. If there was a lock on the bedroom door, he took a hammer and he would break it off. And he'd come in there and he'd say, you are my wife. I've paid for you.
他喝酒时，就像杰基尔博士和海德先生。他开始狂饮。就像，我讨厌回家，因为那个另一个人在那儿。他会变得暴力。我必须去我的卧室，把门封上，把梳妆台推到门前，还有其他任何东西，然后坐在上面。如果卧室门上有锁，他会拿把锤子把它砸掉。他会走进来，说，你是我的妻子。我为你付过钱了。
And maybe that's why the eight years were probably my most precious years with him. Because I didn't have to hear the arguments in the evening if he was drinking. But if he wasn't drinking, he was just a perfect guy. He was just perfect.
也许这就是为什么那八年可能是我和他一起度过的最珍贵的时光。因为如果他在喝酒，我不必在晚上听到争吵。但如果他不喝酒，他就是个完美的人。他简直太完美了。
Our relationship blossomed while he was in prison. While he was in prison.
我们的关系在他入狱时蓬勃发展。在他入狱时。
Janice Powell. A version of this story was originally produced for the Chicago Public Radio series Speaking of Sex. The story was co-produced by Alex Kotlowitz and Amy Drozdowska. Amy did the editing. Thanks, Julia MacAvoy.
贾妮丝·鲍威尔。这个故事的一个版本最初是为芝加哥公共广播电台系列节目《谈论性》制作的。故事由亚历克斯·科特洛维茨和艾米·德罗兹多夫斯卡联合制作。艾米负责编辑。感谢朱莉娅·麦卡沃伊。
Well, this episode of our program was produced by Diane Cook and me, with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, and Starlee Kine. Senior producer for this episode with Julie Snyder. Music help for this show from consigliere Sarah Vowell. Matt Tierney's our technical director. Production help from Diane Wu.
嗯，我们的这个节目是由戴安·库克和我制作的，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、温迪·多尔和斯塔莉·基恩。本集的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。本节目的音乐帮助来自顾问莎拉·沃威尔。马特·蒂尔尼是我们的技术总监。制作帮助来自戴安·吴。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交易所（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Sure, when people meet him, they do walk away with some regrets.
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。当然，当人们见到他时，确实会带着一些遗憾离开。
I don't think we ever asked him any questions about drugs and drug trafficking.
我记得我们从没问过他任何关于毒品和贩毒的问题。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。